[Musique]
ce vendredi 8 décembre 700 personnes
étaient conviées à assister à la
cérémonie de remise des prix des
Trophées des services à la personne
organisé par la Fée des app la
Fédération d'entreprise de service à la
personne et de maintien à domicile au
théâtre champfleuy pour cette deè
édition la soirée était présentée par
Christophe béger accompagné de Dominique
Barret par un de l'événement cette année
le département partenaire de l'événement
était présent pour honorer celles et
ceux qui uvre chaque jour auprès des
familles
réunionnaises le département a cette
compétence en ce qui concerne les
personnes vulnérabl on accompagne cette
associationpoi on est on fait partie de
d'un des partenaires de de l'pi
justement en ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement des personnes
vulnérables l'insertion au niveau
professionnel puisque c'est un secteur
qui est en tension et où on a besoin de
de personnes pour s'uper de et
accompagner nos personnes âgées donc
effectivement c'est ce soir le le
comment dire ça la récompense des de de
nos lauréas c'était pour valoriser
leur exemplarité leur professionnalisme
au service de nos personnes âgées
personnes porteuses de handicap en tout
cas les personnes notre public
vulnérable qui est notre
compétence des trophées qui ont pour
objectif d'encourager l'excellence c'est
de valoriser les métiers des services à
la personne trois catégories définissent
le concours le maintien à domicile les
services à la vie quotidienne et la
petite enfance 11 lauréat ont été
récompensés c'est la première fois qu'il
y a eu une délégation de métropole qui
représentait la la branche
professionnelle ce qui est très
important puisque c'est eux qui votent
les budgets c'est eux qui votent les qui
font les modifications des conventions
collectives et cetera donc c'était ça
c'était une première et puis ensuite
effectivement donc le trophée du jury le
trophée de l'apprentissage c'est des
choses que on souhaite renouveler et qui
nous semble aussi important pour amener
la jeunesse vers vers ces métiers là et
et valoriser aussi la jeunesse
ronise moi je suis ADVF assistant de
famille j'accompagne les personnes j'ai
les aide dans leur tâche ménagère mais
comme dit ça c'est accompagné c'estàdire
je je les aide à garder le autonomie au
début je dois reconnaître que c'était
pas évident mais je peux dire que avec
l'expérience et aussi l'envie d'aider
les autres dever les autres j'ai dit que
je peux dire que c'est pas si difficile
que ça j'arrive à à trouver même ma ma
joie à travailler avec les personnes
dans situ son handicap
et c'est un métier difficile très
prenant mais on fait avec le cœur et
quand on arrive chez la personne on n
tout parce que ben elle nous donne des
sourir elle nous aide à N sentir bien et
nous aide aussi à à à nous valoriser par
rapport à notre pétier elle nous donne
nous pas à domicile mais ça de
nouvelle un prix de 1000 € a été remis
pour les premiers de chaque catégorie
ainsi que de nombreux
lot